you'll recall in Lesson one that
according to Jacob Nielsen's research
with only three users upwards of sixty
five percent of the issues in a
prototype can be uncovered and with only
five users upwards of seventy five
percent of the issues can be found in a
prototype it won't make much sense to do
more than ten user research tests on the
same prototype because of the law of
diminishing returns the key to
effectively applying Nielsen's research
is getting the feedback from three to
five users early on and continuously
iterating on changes as you've made
incremental changes to your design so
after you've made your first round of
feedback make the changes you've
received to your designs then go for
another round of three to five users
after each round or iteration you'll
find that your designs will improve
efficiently